i know this is getting lost in the  shuffle of all the crazy things that are  happening in the wake of the capital  riots but it's important to not lose  sight of the fact that  president trump committed another  impeachable offense  with respect to the georgia election  results we learned recently that one of  the u.s  attorneys for one of the federal  districts in georgia resigned  amid pressure from president trump to  find more  election fraud beyond jay park who was  the u.s attorney for one of the federal  districts  resigned rather than comply with the  president's pressure to  engage in election fraud now i've  already called the  totally improper call between president  trump and secretary of state  brad raffensberger but this alone in and  of itself  is also just as bad and just as  impeachable so let's not lose sight of  that as well  stay tuned for more legal election  coverage and as always i'll see you  in court